make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
it's here
it is here right now let me tell you
something the the the ending really like
not really even the ending of venom
right just like we're we're here at the
end of the king in black right not
officially right this is venom number
34. this is the the last venom story
before king and black ends the very last
venom story comes out after this dude
but this story
is lit all right this this story is it's
so good
but it's so amazing okay so to get you
guys caught up
those of you guys who are who are a
little bit behind here right to get you
guys caught up we're basically picking
up here with flash thompson right now
one of the things that was established
here
is that everybody who's ever been a host
for a symbiote that was in some form or
fashion tied to null so in the case of
flash thompson he was actually a host
for the venom symbiote itself
that essentially a codex is left behind
in your body and so
when you die your essence so to speak
kind of goes to the realm of null right
and so that's why flash thompson
is more or less alive not in a literal
form but kind of uh kind of in the sense
that like his memory
is basically what it is uh was kind of
reformed in the world of null
in the sense that he kind of was able to
take on like a dragon form it's a little
weirdest little wonky watch the last
video and it'll all make sense
but you've basically got uh flash
thompson kind of uh asian anti-venom
who's like just
this giant dragon form fighting off the
dragons of null and then you have null
himself going after eddie brock now
again this really kind of takes place in
the realm of null it's not really here
in the real world but it's one of these
things where eddie's constantly kind of
been on this
move to try to find ways to defeat null
to take out knoll and initially
the only real opportunity they had when
they were in noles realm was to
basically like free the different
symbiotes that had been
liberated right to or at least been
captured right to kind of free them and
allow them to go forward and almost kind
of try to turn the tables against uh
against null but that was caught
on super fast and null immediately shows
up and then goes to attack eddie brock
and so when that happens eddie's able to
fight off
uh fight him off at least for for a
moment or two or at least create a
distraction
but null at the end of the day kind of
continues to get the upper hand and we
expect that right null is astronomically
powerful he's a guy with the ability to
like ensnare celestials and do his all
black and all that kind of stuff and so
he basically tells eddie like
i've i've conquered your world right and
then i'm going to destroy your world
there's nothing you can do to stop me
right like there and there really is at
least not for eddie himself
and so when that happens he starts
bonding eddie to a symbiote right and
it's just kind of like you know this
symbiote will take over you
i'm tired of playing these games i'm
tired of chasing after you
and you you somehow trying to get the
upper hand on me i'm gonna do what i
should have done in the beginning
my symbiote is going to take you over
and when it does you are going to become
one of my servants and then when that
happens he just drops eddie and allows
the symbiote to take hold here's the
funny thing about this right like eddie
eddie kind of has this amazing monologue
when he says it right he says every
moment in my life repeats itself when i
walked into that church
the world fell black around me and then
i was beaten time and time again like
when i was a child
and now those sins that darkness that
lived inside me
that have now rained down on the earth
like they did on me
all those years ago it will start again
with the world
with my son it's all part of the cycle
ashes to ashes
dust to dust and as he's going through
this monologue and as he's really kind
of musing this idea
that his life struggle is almost kind of
a reflection of what's happening out
there right in the sense that like the
world is falling apart
the world's being conquered by what
seems to be this insurmountable force
that nobody can stand against
suddenly a voice chimes in eddie are you
there can you hear me it's the venom
symbiote man like the venom symbiote
found any right like it was it was
originally taken by null and it's just
kind of been biting its time
waiting to find eddie and it broke free
right so like now the venom symbiotes
bonded back to eddie brock's memory and
as soon as that happens it bolts and
null's just like
no no so pissed right because he thought
it was destroyed like he thought that
simi was kind of destroyed captured
whatever now the immediate question
that's answered
by donnie kate's in writing this is how
is it that the symbiote can bond itself
to eddie
if eddie's physical body is out there in
the real world and this is answered by
saying like it's basically just a memory
right that's the nature of a codex the
codex is the memory of the person who
was the host of the symbiote at one
point in time
and so outside the realm of null and in
the real world
this codex of eddie brock would be
intangible right it wouldn't really be
able to interact with anything but
inside the realm of null and because of
the fact that it's a symbiote
uh it basically bonds itself to the
memory right so it's like it's like
bonding yourself to an intangible thing
and then in turn it just kind of like
breaks out into the real world and says
like we have to go to the real world we
have to find your physical body we have
to fight
null out there and so basically they
leave the realm of null due to the power
of the symbiote and then emerge out into
the real world and when that happens
eddie brock takes on this
massive form and when i say massive i
mean like enormous right he's got to be
like five or six hundred feet tall right
he's just he's
huge now size does not always equal
strength right and so while he is huge
and everything in relation to null he's
still
fairly weak and that's the crazy thing
because flash thompson comes flying in
and it's like dude is that you and he's
like yeah man it's me dude he's like
okay do you need some help he's like
nope i got this right i have this on my
own eddie goes immediately after null
and he tells flash he
he asked him like do you remember what
happened to cletus when he got a dragon
symbiote and the response of flash is
like i wasn't alive for that right like
i wasn't i was i was dead when that
happened i wasn't here for that and
eddie's like
go find out right like it's like believe
me you want to go find out what happened
i got this right so he kind of sends
flash thompson on his own mission at
that point
eddie immediately goes after nulc and
for the most part like the symbiote's
telling him like
no like do not go after null and we
don't get an initial reason why right
the the reality kind of seems to be that
the symbiote's like you're not in a
position to face off against null yet
but the truth is that something's coming
right the god of light is coming and we
remember this from the last video right
we remember this remember
we remember this from the last video
none of the churches are remember this
from the last video the god of light is
coming
and and and it's it's it comes it goes
swooping in right and the cymbia is like
look right like like this is it eddie
like this is what we were warned about
right the god of light is finally here
like i felt him
right he's he's he's kind of like us but
different his light is approaching
blinding screaming roaring like just
just like literally come just ripping
right through there right
and then as soon as that happens it
bonds itself to the memory of eddie and
then then the memory of eddie is yanked
away from the symbiote and he's kind of
like like do not leave me again right
and the symbiote's like no no no i will
find you right i always find you
i will find you eddie brock and then
like the memory of eddie is ripped apart
right it's literally torn apart and then
at that moment you switch back over to
the body of eddie this in the possession
of reed richards and all these other
guys and you jump back to the ending of
the last video that we did
where you basically end up learning that
this force of energy had always been
misunderstood by the superheroes right
that this energy source has been has
recognized by reed richards they've seen
it a million times before
they've just been calling it by the
wrong name that the the enigma force has
finally been solved this is eddie brock
becoming captain universe
and it's the craziest thing ever son
like literally it bonds itself because
the the the you know captain universe
basically like talks to eddie right it
talks to him and says like
you've been chosen to be the protector
of your world and the savior of the
universe right so
what form do you want eddie brock tell
me the form that you want to choose
right it's it's crazy because he's like
there's only ever been one answer to
that question
but before we find out what that answer
is we switch over to flash thompson so
so so ancient anti-venom flash thompson
is just like flying you know through the
cemetery finding out what happened to
cletus cassidy when he was bonded to a
dragon symbiote and it's just kind of
nuts
because when he's in arlington he talks
about how like this this power is kind
of different right it's ancient it's
strange you know and and somehow it's a
little bit familiar this dragon goes
diving down into one of the graves and
then it basically has like flash
thompson talking about like he doesn't
really know what he is
he doesn't know if it'll be enough to
beat back the void but all he knows is
that he's back
right that win or lose good or bad light
or dark that everything is about to
change
and what we end up having here is flash
thompson's hand reaching out from the
grave flash thompson's coming back y'all
agent venom
is coming back son and i have no idea
what it means but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and i will catch you
all later peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you